en esta época de pandemia dubai hizo una
apuesta arriesgada es uno de los pocos
destinos abiertos a los viajeros de todo
el mundo
las aerolíneas distribuyen kits de
protección que parecen bandejas de
comida en los vuelos nacionales a su
llegada a todos los pasajeros deben
someterse a una prueba de pcr si los
resultados son negativos los turistas
pueden desplazarse libremente al pie del
burj al arab a uno de los símbolos de la
ciudad estos franceses vinieron a
disfrutar de las temperaturas ideales
del golfo pérsico en esta época al igual
que decenas de miles de turistas
europeos todas las actividades están
disponibles
por eso vinimos aquí el propietario de
esta empresa de deportes acuáticos debe
seguir las instrucciones sanitarias cómo
desinfectar las motos acuáticas y los
chalecos salvavidas después de cada uso
pero en dubai el sector turístico que se
vio fuertemente afectado mundialmente
pudo abrir y aprovechar la temporada
alta y se está recuperando muy bien en
comparación con otros países europeos
como francia aquí no tenemos ninguna
ayuda no decidimos mantener todo nuestro
equipo y sin esta apertura no habríamos
podido hacerlo habríamos tenido que
despedir a nuestros empleados reducir
nuestra plantilla y probablemente
incluso cerrar el grupo
tras un primer confinamiento estricto en
la primavera del 2020 las autoridades
optaron por abrir a toda costa y el país
se encargó de hacérselo saber al mundo
entero
en software de las mismas
wow
[Música]
para impulsar su economía dubai ofrece
incluso una visa de teletrabajo el
objetivo es atraer a los llamados
nómadas digitales este neozelandés
decidió irse de berlín para escapar de
los confinamientos en europa es como si
todas las mañanas me despertara con la
vista de la torre eiffel
es un poco así ni un fundador de una
empresa emergente de transferencia de
dinero por internet planea trabajar
desde este espacio de coworking hasta
que se restablezcan las conexiones
aéreas en todo el planeta
en fin hay mucha gente interesada
conozca gente que vive en bali y que
viene a dubai conozco a muchos nómadas
digitales en españa' o berlín que van a
instalarse aquí porque sienten que la
situación es mejor en dubai que en otros
lugares que hay menos incertidumbre
otro argumento de dubai para convencer a
estos teletrabajadores de que se
instalen aquí es que todos tendrán
acceso a la campaña de vacunación masiva
que los emiratos pusieron en marcha
desde principios de año ya se han
administrado tres millones de dosis cada
día son vacunados gratuitamente cerca de
100.000 personas independientemente de
su edad o estado de salud algunas
empresas incluso envían a sus empleados
en buses enteros para que sean vacunados
una operación que ha sido posible
gracias a una elección única en el mundo
la vacuna china del laboratorio
scinopharm los servicios sanitarios de
los emiratos árabes unidos afirman que
la vacuna tiene una efectividad del 86
por ciento aunque todavía no se han
publicado los resultados científicos que
demuestren esta cifra nuestro objetivo
aquí los emiratos es vacunar a el 50 por
ciento de la población antes de marzo
esto nos permitirá con la ayuda de dios
rebajar las restricciones sanitarias y
que no haya más confinamientos estas
decisiones de salud pública no son
objeto de debate en esta monarquía
absoluta para fomentar la vacunación los
restaurantes obligados a funcionar al 70
por ciento de su capacidad
ofrecen incluso descuentos sorprendentes
todo está bien en esta cervecería
francesa vincent a la que ofrece un 10%
de descuento para quienes hayan recibido
su primera dosis de la vacuna contra el
joven y un 20% de descuento para quienes
ya se han puesto el refuerzo tenemos
suerte todo está abierto en dubai pero
nos gusta que las cosas fueran aún más
rápido así que nos dijimos un 10% o un
20% no es mucho pero podría motivar a la
gente a vacunarse muchas gracias
esto sí es vida
me vacuné la semana pasada no tuve que
esperar un hospital en el último momento
tomé la decisión y me vacuné en menos de
una hora
tengo la segunda dosis en tres semanas y
no tengo que preguntarme si la vacuna va
a estar disponible
durante las vacaciones este restaurante
tuvo sus mejores ventas desde su
apertura hace cinco años los hoteles de
la ciudad han incluso recuperado la
misma tasa de ocupación que antes de la
pandemia para este economista esta
política de apertura se explica por la
ausencia de reservas de hidrocarburos en
dubai los emiratos vecinos ricos en
petróleo y gas como abu dhabi qatar y
kuwait han permanecido cerrados a los
turistas
es muy importante que dubai se abra a
los visitantes
el turismo representa el 15 por ciento
del producto interno bruto y su
estrategia de crecimiento se basa en
gran medida en el sector turístico y la
recuperación tras la crisis dependerá de
la llegada de viajeros
es una decisión de alto riesgo desde las
fiestas de fin de año la tasa de
contagio que hasta entonces se mantenía
estable en torno a 1000 casos en 24
horas se ha triplicado en los últimos
días las autoridades de dubai tuvieron
que restablecer las restricciones
cerrando bares y discotecas